foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
it's it's the same with you know teams
calls you know your microphones off your
cameras are I just
when will it ever stop
and the problems with the microphones
you're as the last one to know that your
microphone isn't isn't on but there we
go
yes I had the uh a company site
inspection this morning so I did view
from Johnny K Lane and I was pleased
that the um
the weather forecast that I saw on TV
this morning was not accurate and there
wasn't
a section and the council provided with
me with a Google Street View image of
the site from that branches point but
before the development was actually
carried out
so by word comparison
um I went higher up the slope on Johnny
Gate Lane but um
as far as I could see you couldn't see
the site from
other sections of Johnny Gate Lane
because of
um well topography because of Hedges
Banks dry stone walls Etc there may be
points along there we could see it but I
didn't notice any
but from the site itself obviously I
could see across the slope so I could
see across the valley to
um
where there are some buildings on them
date at that point for resumption so and
also
um
given the the absence for example the
proofs in relation to appeal a the
absence of a statement a common ground
there was an opportunity for some case
management that and I took that
opportunity
so gave some directions for wanted a
better expression for the progress of
the case thereafter and that was all
explained in my the email that was sent
out on the 1st of September so what I'm
saying is clearly
the fact that that event that the the
inquiry opened on that day was at least
partly down to me
um but there were reasons there were
reasons why I I did that
right
in relation to to cost you heard the
um discussion for whatever reason I I
don't blame the cards I didn't get a
copy on the amended costs claim last
night Mr leithhead has sent it to me at
this point and it's coming through so I
got that at 11 22. uh I haven't even
opened it I was doing something else and
what I want to make sure is that they I
understand the nature of the claim and I
also need just to make some corrections
if you know based on what you've just
said so what I propose is I mean I can
open the email about probably better
let's do closings I would have thought
yeah then Mr leaflet makes his
application I'll hear what that is I'm
then going to see a bit of time uh and
depending on what's said that may not be
uh yeah I may not need very long I I may
need more time I have a printer I would
make some changes to the written
responses I've got so the response that
I amended last night
was amended based on what I now know
about the original claim so I hadn't
seen the amended claim and I certainly
haven't been able to deal with it that's
fine
thank you okay
um I I said suddenly it's only slightly
amended
um um it wasn't it was sent to the
writing mode I was like 45 but he's got
it now
um um and and I've clarified that the
substantive costs
um are
the whole way through the inquiry um I
think it's it's it's probably it was
perhaps how I thought but there was a
reference to 6th 6th of September
um of course the ground seat appear was
removed after the September so
unfortunately it's clear it was going to
be on that date
um but um but for the avoidance of any
doubts the substantive claim is is up to
the present day
it doesn't stop us doing closings but
yeah that's fine
um and just before we get off the topic
of costs um I still haven't worked out
exactly how they should be the
application should be dealt with I
haven't had an opportunity to speak to
anyone in the costs and decisions team
it's not the first time I've had
um linked appeals and where one of the
appeals is withdrawn
but I think it's the first time I've had
a situation where it's so difficult to
disentangle one from the other in terms
of cost implications so
um I will need to speak to the cost
decisions team but the E is this way is
from here everything I need to hear and
then speak up about how it should be how
it should be dealt with
um it's just as I said yesterday when it
comes to writing the appeal decision
there won't be an appeal position on a
pla there'll be nothing more than a
reference in appeal B to the fact that
there was a PLA and it's been withdrawn
because there's nothing for me to
determine and really following on from
that there's nothing for me to determine
in terms of cost it's for the um as I
said really strict with the secretary
state but I've just got to work out how
that works in in practice
um as I said before when I've had it
before it's been quite straightforward
you can say well a pla is gone
everything to do with the pla the costs
you know we'll deal with that but
there's a bit of an overlap here which
is a bit more a bit more tricky so
it may all become clear to me after
another night's sleep but we'll see
right so um if you're if you're already
used to leave it um we can just hear
your closing submissions
is there something
no an enforcement is the the penalty
gets the last
thank you sir
uh these aren't supposed to feedback
better
okay so these are the closing
submissions on behalf of the council
the council's case is set out in the
various document submitted in particular
proof of Mr Julian Hawley and Mr Joanne
Edwards pla as pla was withdrawn belly
pregnant immediately before the inquiry
commenced no submissions are made in
relation to that
appeal B ground a Mr Hall is explained
why the appeal should fail underground
Aid Andy and that's in his proof and his
rebuttal proof uh numerous weaknesses of
The Apprentice cases someone has a
paragraph of 33 of the councils updated
cost application to which I'll turn in
due course
in outline the appellant is a long way
from demonstrating that very special
circumstances exist to justify granting
planning permission for these
substantially inappropriate developments
you chose to develop in the green belt
within a special landscape area which is
valued landscape for the purposes of
paragraph 174 of the mppf uh used to
identify the following main issues in
your agenda inquiry effects of the new
garage and unfinished building on the
openness of the green belt the effects
of the new garage and unfinished
building on the character and appearance
of the locality within an area of
primary landscape sensitivity
and and see whether any harm by a
reasonable inappropriateness and any
other harm would be clearly outweighed
by other considerations so as to amount
to the very special circumstances
required to justify The Proposal
uh
first the impact on the of the
unauthorized buildings on openness
as you said we'll be aware the courts
have identified a number of matters
which needs to be taken into account
considering openness that these include
spatial and visual aspects the duration
of the development and its remediability
the new garage the new garage is a
significant development with the volume
calculates to be 387 meters cubed it
increases the footprint and volume of
built developments on the land to a
substantial extent and has a
substantially negative effect on the
openness of the green birds in special
terms and the degree of activity life
needs to be generated such as traffic
generation
uh in visual terms the new garage
significantly increases the massive
development which is highly visible from
the main public Highway especially
during winter and spring months it's
highly visible both within the site and
from immediately adjoining lands and
currently developed land that was
previously open that was previously open
absent of any built development
this results in substantial harm to the
openness of the green birds and visual
terms
Palm to the openness of the green belt
would further be caused by the domestic
activities for which the new garage
would be used including regular vehicle
vehicle movements
as there would be no reason prospects
the land being returned to its original
state of Washington equivalent to
improved state of openness it would
further be harmed opponent building
would always be visible and so any any
impacts upon openness would endure for
the long term
unfinished building in spatial terms The
Unfinished building where the volume
calculated at 587 meters cubed and that
excludes the Dormer windows of the front
rear and side elevations has an even
greater negative impact on the openness
of the green belt in addition it further
significantly increases the massive
development which is visible from the
land from the from adjoining land and
it's highly visible from the adjacent
main public Highway especially during
the winter and spring months and it
raises the height of running
considerably above the pre-existing
situation but consequently it has a
substantially negative effect on
openness in visual terms like the new
charity and finished building is a
substantial employment structure which
also results in harm to the openness of
the green belt there's further certainly
no reasonable Prospect the land would be
returned to its visual state or to an
equivalent to improve state of openness
opponent building would always be
visible and so any impacts upon openness
would endure for the long term
inclusion on openness for the reasons
above the unauthorized building that was
substantially negative impact on the
openness of the green vote both
individually and humans
the harm to the openness of the
Greenville furthers the effect that the
purposes of the Greenbelt are set out in
mppf program 138 are undermined and
particularly the apparent urban sprawl
uh and and by the way there should be an
under and by the way in which they
encroach into the countryside there's
two of the five points there
um the impact of the unauthorized
buildings on character and appearance
landscape character landscape
characterization is the process that
defines what makes an area uniquely
different from another area
are set out in the technical support
documents produced by the County Council
primary landscape areas in the county
fall within areas of multiple
environmental sensitivity which areas of
landscape that have been identified as
being sensitive with respect to a range
of environmental data sets the slice has
been a primary landscape area primary
landscape errors are those with the
highest sensitivity and which are most
likely to be negatively affected by
change or development these are areas
where the landscape remains intact both
visually and structurally have strong
historic and cultural identity and
contain many widespread semi-natural
habitats the associated linkages are
appropriate to the character of the area
the site is further identified as being
within the Derbyshire Peak Fringe and
lower down the character areas and
within the wooded slopes and valleys
character type the relevant landscape
character description it explains the
features of this character area the key
characteristics can be summarized as up
and unrelated ground rising to Moorland
slopes and moderates are Steep and
steeping along stream valleys permanent
pasture for sheep and very cattle
densely scattered small to medium
ancient woodlands and secondary Woodland
on steeper slopes and along the streams
clearly scattered Hedgerow trees the
regular field pattern bounded by mixed
species hedgerows chlorestone walls are
widespread defining a more regular field
pattern network of Winding Lane sunk on
steeper slopes with Rocky Banks his
first Sandstone parameters with stone
slate Roots the majority of historic
buildings are constructed and looked
with Sand and Stone traditionally roofed
with stone sleeves balances are
dispersed throughout the landscape they
are occasionally clusters of farmsteads
and cottages
a strong focus on the protection and
conservation of the environmental and
built environmental and environment
assets
in terms of the local plan landscape
character and primary Landscapes
Institute in particular is relevant to
policy
sdc3 which says the developments will
only be permitted where it would not
just cause significant harms of the
character of quality distinctiveness or
sensitivity of the landscape
but finally as already stated the
penalty perception of the landscape in
which the site sits is valued landscape
purposes of paragraph 174 of the mpbo
impact of the unauthorized buildings on
character and appearance about a new
garage I mentioned above the local
vernacular with Sandstone Farm stairs
with stone slate roofs the new garages
constructed on Timber which is not
representative of garages and the
locality we tend to be stone or a
mixture of stone and Timber
even agricultural buildings are not
typically constructed with Timber
um
there's a typo there
um
Timber buildings are more typical for
equestrian development
not only is the building out of keeping
the wider area it doesn't even fit with
the host welding print would a house as
you have seen in your site visit this
morning so
as to the impact of the building on the
landscape more generally it is built in
an elevated position on the site and
it's visually prominent When approaching
from the south especially in the winter
and spring months the building is
further visible within the backdrop of
rising land and Scattered Woodland
forming the ridge line
represents urbanizing built form which
purchase development east across the
Contour towards open pastoral land it
harms local distinctiveness as it is an
alien and substantial domestic
outputting in an agricultural landscape
the size that would be your significant
because it fail to respect the scale
proportions and character of the
surrounding Properties or landscape
the building is located a significant
distance from the dwelling with the
effect that it lacks any intimate
association with Brentwood house as
would be expected of the domestic
carriage
and then the unfinished voting uh as it
really stated the local vernacular is
sandstone Farm says with stone slate
rules the unfinished building is
constructed from Timber parks and
cladding and as large areas of glazing
design terms it is an awkward and
unusual arrangement of Timber clad
Gables floor to ceiling glazing panels
and normal Windows it harms local
distinctiveness caused by an alien of
substantial domestic outbuilding but in
science design and appearance in either
representative or functional
agricultural buildings within the
dispersed pharmacists or domestic
outbuildings which will possess an
element of subordination the building
further represents an urbanizing built
form which extends to Ireland east
across the Contours towards open
parceland and within the agricultural
landscape
whilst house is an immediate vicinity
are typically more modern construction
are rather typically more modern
construction design they're intimately
contained
is resulting in an unacceptable sprawl
of development which impacts
unacceptably on the site in its
surroundings it appears as a new
isolated dwelling in the countryside
built in an elevated position on the
site the average building is visually
prominent to an approaching in the South
especially in winter and spring months
it is visible within the backdrop of
rising lands and Scattered Woodland
forming an original and open pastoral
and below
harm caused by the building is
compounded by the fact that it was
obviously unfinished as shown in the
photograph at page eight of this all his
proof
relation to a deemed application under
Section 1771 uh planning permission is
granted in respect to the matters stated
in the enforcement notice as
constituting a breach of planning
control in Holland pot the effects of
this is that what was not completed the
time that the thought of this is kind of
been repeated by ground a in case of
that as we discussed into Arnold in the
case of the unfinished building Uso
could not lawfully required completion
even if you were minded to do so just
pausing there and I didn't text um
briefly and the building's been the
purposes that would have been described
in different ways at different times uh
as I understand it was a party room at
one stage and now it's just a golfing
room
um
you would have seen on the site visit
they look like material that would be
used for for flooring repellent uh uh
claims it's finished and that there's no
intention to put another floor in uh
looking at the building it does seem
that um
that's unlikely but that's really
beautiful form of judgment so
and the appellant has suggested that it
could be completed without planning
permission uh but it certainly is not
clear how it could be and no plans have
been provided to demonstrate this
finding the size of building a
significant and further to respect the
scale proportions in characterless
surrounding Properties or a landscape
and they find an inclusion on landscape
impacts
and for the reasons about the pudding
has a significantly detrimental effect
on the local land gate within the area
of primary landscape sensitivity which
is concentrated with the national and
local policy
and then the fallback position arising
from committed development rights the
dependent's case on various special
circumstances is largely dependent on
his alleged fallback position arising
from permitted development rights while
the appellants abandoned his initial
claim that the unauthorized buildings
benefit from primitive otherwise sort of
Class A he argues that other buildings
could be within the cartilage of
Brentwood House not Brentwood
uh Lancashire the Lancashire appeal in
support the appendant relies on an
appeal decision in Lancashire mentioned
by Mr Telford in his evidence over the
opponent's been unable to provide the
equal decision and the council has
similarly been unable to locate it
notwithstanding this it's a plant from
the hospital supplied by Mr Telford that
the circumstances of the two appeals are
different language appeal involved
parked Vehicles whereas the present
matches so the two large unauthorized
structures with a greater negative
impact on the green belt and on the
local currency and immunity the parent
buildings would always be visible and so
any impacts upon openness will endure
for the long term in any event I need a
very limited weight could be granted in
a pill decision but it's not falling
inquiry and cannot be located
limitations of Class E but further
difficulty Independence argument is that
the unauthorized buildings do not come
within the limitations of Class E the
reasons including that they do not come
within the size restrictions and there's
two separate paragraphs and for that so
the university is section 10 and 11 of
Mr hawley's proof even though it's
within what was round C
and the effect is that the same
buildings could not be constructed
within the cartilage of Greenwood house
and benefit from the Community
Development rights under Class E so
conclusion on the forward position of
very special circumstances but the most
that can be said about the appendix
fallback position is that some sort of
buildings could lawfully be built
somewhere in the cartilage of
brindlewood house though no clouds exist
as to what the buildings would be or
where they might go further the amount
of engineering work that would be
required to level the land would further
prevent the appendant from relying on
Class E and then where developments in
the green road is inappropriate by
definition
they're planning pressure may only be
granted where the harm by reason of
inappropriateness and any other harm is
clearly outweighed by other
considerations so this amounts of the
very special circumstances necessary to
justify the development
overall the opponent has not come close
to demonstrating very special
circumstances the ground has no merit
ground F the significant materials used
in the construction of the unauthorized
buildings was built onto the land solely
for their development retention of these
materials were not specifies and unknown
purpose is unreasonable thus they
require that they should be removed
there's no further than that which is
necessary to remedy the breach
underground F should fail
at Ground G after the inquiry Zine on
the first December 2022 the planet
indicated that these sorts rely on
ground G the council's position is
simply the nurses provide adequate time
in order to comply and this relaxer at a
modest increase in this time period of
Inspector is out of the view that it is
warranted
um for the business above and in the
council's evidence is your own
respective advice to dismiss
the appeals so before I always I just
turned my side of my name
you know maybe
just following on from this morning side
visited for me
um lots of frequency well I don't know
what you're going to say but it's not
not really appropriate to have further
Evidence at this point yeah but yeah
um
but I do want to ask about what you said
about ground F because Mr Hawley
indicated yesterday that there were a
number of respects in which the
requirements could be
[Music]
I think there was um a question about
drafting of the notice yes so there's
not really listing them but say it in a
different way perhaps well the one was
to
remove
the requirement about
hard standing yeah now I take it I
understand that that's because Mr Hawley
never intended all of the half sanity
but on the face of it the notice May
and changing its requirements
it doesn't really matter how I
characterize it
now I just wanted to um I I thought I
mean the Castle's not grown back from
anything which is it's just not said it
as well as it might have done okay
um
thank you
thank you very much
yes Mr hardy
thank you
thank you
very much and then before I turn to my
text obviously have the right to that
response and we'll make it
a little bit of feedback that just makes
some observations I think the the
overarching point is that and it's one
that has characterized the council's
case they're closing submissions with
respect are just trying a little bit too
hard uh they are exaggerated and in some
ways uh overwritten and just to pick up
on uh the detail of that landscape
character uh if we can turn to paragraph
19.
um
where the
landscape character description for the
area is set out
I mean the underlying character
appraisal came in very late fair enough
but come on this is a
um this is a house with a garden uh
there's no credible suggestion uh that
this is a uh you know an lnv character
case involving key characteristics in
the broader area
21 and the local plan
uh interestingly there's no suggestion
that we breach as DC3
where that policy states the development
only admitted where it wouldn't cause
significant harm to the character
quality distinctiveness or sensitivity
of the landscape it sort of floated but
it's not suggested that we do bridge
that of course we don't I mean the idea
that there is significant harm from
these buildings in the residential
context that they're in to the character
area is it just doesn't Stack Up
at it in 22
uh the there's reference to the valued
landscape we come back to that in
closing uh yes it's accepted that it's a
valid landscape but of course the policy
test is preserver enhanced uh and you uh
got the evidence yesterday from Mr
Telford which is that we're not making
it we're not putting it too high we're
saying that there is no harm there for
there is um there's preservation well
just a moment there does isn't it
preserve and enhance let me just double
check
okay shape my way through my filing
system yes
protect and enhance and enhance yes but
in my view is that you can't
um I mean otherwise why would you have
both as a requirement
because if you've got to enhance in
every case you don't need to protect you
well
I suppose yeah I mean it could end it
because the old debate with conservation
areas and so on whether it's preserve or
enhance
or enhance is definitely sufficient to
preserve
but I suppose
um that there may be circumstances in
which
um
notwithstanding the uh General value of
the landscape you have a site which is
pretty poor and it doesn't take much to
actually and you don't want to preserve
it you know you you've got the
opportunity to to enhance
I mean there's no allegation that in
fact that there's a breach here
paragraph at 174 I'm just picking up by
way of response but we say look in the
residential context there is no harm to
your valued landscape I don't need to go
further than that impact then of the um
uh of the buildings
um
only been on site this morning it just
this doesn't uh ring true with what you
but with what you've seen I suspect it's
been written I know Chris and the Mr
leader sorry which paragraph you're
going to see in the section which starts
23 on the new garage uh I mean I suspect
we're written before Mr Lee said I
hadn't been on site
um now that uh we've all been on site
this does not ring uh true so 26
impacted the building of the landscape
more generally visually prominent When
approaching from the sun it's not when
it's discernible but it's absolutely not
visually prominent that's exaggerated
um 28.
um the the garage harms local
distinctiveness as it's an alien and
substantial domestic outbuilding in a in
an in an agricultural landscape I mean
again come on
uh 30 the building is located a
significant distance from the dwelling
um it isn't as you saw uh this morning
it lacks any intimate Association it's a
garage it's a sloping cycle garage which
serves the house
um unfinished building
paragraph 32 there isn't a an objection
to this ski relation to desire but in
design terms it's an awkward and unusual
Arrangement that doesn't seem to take
the the matter any further this is about
spatial development not about the design
which may not to be to The council's
Taste but that's a by the by 35 houses
in the immediate vicinity are typically
more modern Construction and design
they're intimately contained well that's
exactly what this property is you can't
see it that was agreed really yesterday
again third line up from the bottom
built in an elevated position The
Unfinished building is visually
prominent When approaching from the
south no it may be accepted that there's
it's more discernible uh than the garage
but we do not we don't accept his visual
prominent you can pick it out but it's
not uh prominent uh would indicate
something of Greater magnitude than that
36
uh harm caused by the bunnies compounded
by the fact that it was um obviously
unfinished I think what's become obvious
is the council's got a problem with this
uh and the and in my view it's a problem
with understanding and Mr Leaf had went
off uh of his uh written submissions
today to say well they were building
materials on the soft flooring materials
and so on
looking at the law anything that's
internal to that property does not need
Planning Commission
anything which is done externally has
got to have a material effect
on the external appearancing character
the building and planning terms is
finished no it's not the the finished
article it's not the building as you
would just go and use it tomorrow but
that's not the planning question and the
work that's required the filling in of
those uh the gaps at the back whether
that's uh I haven't had time to check
the plans but whether that's glazing or
whatever and you have you are not going
to be able to discern a material effect
on the character and appearance of that
building from enclosure on that side it
is finished it was finished at the time
the enforcement noticed and that's the
sensible pragmatic View
in terms of flooring materials uh Mr
lathan's point was uh was a poor one
because you need to floor the ground
floor it's not the case of it there's
some sort of suggestion or we might be
putting in a might be putting in a uh
you know a first floor absolutely not
but you need to you need to put floors
down on the you know on the ground floor
so uh that was again I think an example
of that exaggeration of overability May
I just um uh and if necessary Mr League
head can comment but obviously you'll
get the last um comment on this but in
terms of
um material effect on the external
appearance yes
um what do you say because you
you've referred there to enclosure of
the rear so the northern the northern
elevation whatever that's going to be
whether it's glazing or whatever and um
I mean having heard what's intended for
the use of that building and given that
there's lots of insulation material and
so on
inevitably it's going to be enclosed
otherwise it's kind of no point in the
insulation material but or anything else
but
um when assessing materiality of
external appearance what do you say is
the
and I don't want this to obviously get
into evidence but I think it's a matter
of law really as well what do you say
it'll be a matter of fact for the
decision maker but that to me would be
the the structural elements of the
building so that would be the that's
framework that's Roofing that's very
strong so I was thinking more in terms
of where you can see things from
material
by
I think that's the factor
which can be taken a bit like change to
landscape character whatever is it you
know you've got a it's perception isn't
it but where do people perceive that
from I'm not saying that you you know
there is an objective test as well but I
think you could place weights on the
fact you just aren't going to see if you
put like I I genuinely don't know what's
going on about it but if you were to say
put plays in the past nobody's going to
see that at all it's going to be of no
um it would not be seen from any vantage
point or indeed private viewing uh area
given where that that that that glazing
or or whatever it is on the ground
but in terms of the test
um materiality it is a matter of fact
and degree but the it is so minor in
relation to the structure of that
building that it might be in planning
terms you wouldn't be planning to
and even if you did um then of course
you finish it up and that that would be
the there's so much of that building
that's completed that you can obviously
any Grand concern for what's done at the
time the enforcement notice but
um it's something I come back to in my
uh in my closing submissions I I
commented yesterday on that that um
Eastern
Gable end
um which was parked look like that's
been Cloud now with with Timber yeah
uh yeah so it's it I mean there are bits
and Buzz but even if you are going to
put you know uh Stone tiles or whatever
it is I I in my view
um that does not mean the addition of
one stone tile uh that you know that
that that therefore has a material
effect on on couch ability it's got to
be more than it could be a sensible view
taken at that and therefore
the principal elements of that building
and they're all absolutely there so our
view is that it's it's uh you could
finish that without any with that
population so I'll come back to you did
you want to say anything Mr Leaf head
about this question of material
impact on external appearance and well
so and what was already said in in the
round table session no
um Mr hardy doesn't know how the
building is going to be uh finished
um
he's submitting its obvious
um it isn't obvious to me
um how that building could be finished
without
affecting the external appearance
um
so my question was more not so much
about what's going to happen on that
elevation but how significant it is in
terms of
um you know whether it's we all know for
example that
let's not complicate this but um
if you can't see it from public Vantage
points does is that relevant to the
question of whether the material
material impact no
they're with me
foreign
well the the reason I I couldn't
remember the name of the case but it's
Burrows day versus Bristol county or
city council 1996.
um in summary the works for the works to
materially affect external appearance
the changes must be visible from a
number of Vantage points and material to
the appearance of the building as a
whole
um material materially affecting the
external appearance means an impact
capable of having some affecting
planning terms
I was aware of that therefore there is
there's a difference in law uh it's one
of the cases which I'm going to uh
submit so there's a I mean I might say
the council's run in the law uh
yeah I've still got to interpret that
apply it but
um that's why I was asking the question
that I think it's not entirely
irrelevant that you if you can't see it
from public Advantage points
this is a number Advantage points
it's it's it's a part of the change I'm
looking really from the having
encyclopedia it's dealt with at 55.17
p55.17
um the issue is where there's certain
Works to enlisted building Constitution
development required planning permission
It Works include a provision of a lift
shaft housing which involved alteration
to the roof and placement of Windows the
front television the building the Court
held the works did not constant
development was not sufficient merely
that work should be should affect the
exterior of the building so that's what
they should materially affect the
external appearance nursing
practitioners from a number of normal
rods points visibility from the air or
from a single building would not be uh
sufficient
um
it's it's going to involve a planning
judgment
from you so we what what can be said is
there were no plans before you as to how
that building could be
completed I mean we have no evidence on
earth and the appellant about
it it's it's a very tall for a bungalow
or have it might be described as seen
single story building it's you need to
perform your own feel on that yeah
whether there's one or two internal
flaws and I'm not sure he's particularly
relevant to material impact effects
there are a number of gaps in the
outside of the building I think on on
sides even the side that faces towards
yeah
some of it's part glazed yeah there are
there's a sort of narrow shallow
openings
um which aren't glazed and some of the
main Windows aren't aren't Blaze but but
um
I
no um
maybe I was wrong to assume I was
assuming those narrow long rectangular
openings would be glazed as well but I
don't perhaps I shouldn't have assumed
that
okay anyways just that point of
principle about so since your chords I'm
I'm literally just to create a factual
Point
um it's I I practically respect myself
as clearly as it might I said that it
was contrary to local and National
policy we are alleging a breach of
scc3
um and in fact that's in the notice
itself
so which you'll see at um I'll just get
it
it was up it's gone
um that is at
um paragraph four of the
um of notice B it says the developers
therefore contrite local plan policies
GS2 gs6 h11 and any two contrary to EOP
policies ss9 ss10 lc5 and stc3 and and
Coach universe and ppf policies as well
thanks sir thank you right sorry about
that diversion
um but I mean I'm slightly concerned
about the council having another go but
there we go well I I was gonna the thing
about the thing the thing about
um
um
whether it's a breach of sd3 I had noted
that the council had said that Mr Luther
had said in closing there was a breach
of local and National policies but I had
forgotten about the reference in the in
the enforcement notice itself but that's
a fair point uh also I mean the council
clearly had been applying the wrong test
because you've got a clear answer from
Mr Lee said that it wasn't relevant and
borrows day of course says that it is in
terms of materiality so um whilst that
then was softened to it being planning
judgment it's clear that the if that has
informed the Council of judgment then
it's wrong
so in this case there are views uh and
anything that was done on that back
elevation won't be seen from Vantage
points and in planning terms that
building is uh is finished
uh going back to uh the closings then of
Mr Leith Edward's reference to the
Lancashire appeal in his paragraph 43
onwards I'm afraid of Mr Boeing
the
um the transferable principle from that
appeal you don't need an appeal to uh to
to to to to make the point but what is
clear from the reference is that uh
rather than have an open air parking use
it's better to put the vehicles uh in uh
to contain them and contain the vision
or in this case you've seen the hard
standing uh and the number of vehicles
and we'll come back to that in my own
closing but that um hard standing is
excluded from the enforcement notice
that will be used to park those Vehicles
including uh equestrian uh horse boxes
RVs and so on so the point of the
principle the the reference is to
uh The Beneficial effect of putting
Vehicles inside uh a purpose-built and
garage
limitations class
in a limitation is a Class C paragraph
47.
um again this is the point really the
effect is that the same buildings
couldn't be constructed within the Kurds
energy Greenwood house and benefited it
from the permitted development rights on
the class C well you just have a the
point is a qualifying Builder so you
know the advice absolutely uh as you've
heard would be to um submit A Clockwork
but the the metrics are understood so it
would be a modified building
uh which then maxes out those classy uh
rights so the proposition is the
buildings right absolutely got that
building but but a modified building
absolutely can and would
terms of
51 overall the appellant is not composed
to demonstrating very special
circumstances the ground has no marriage
it's a sort of sounds to be borrowed
from a kind of Court pleading of course
the grounds got married we've been
discussing it for a day and a bit uh
Council May disagree but it's just that
just the flavor I think of how the
council Mr Lee Taylor approached this
uh so those are my comments in relation
to what he's got to say if I can turn to
my own closing submissions then it's
unfortunate that the
it's really following this theme that
the enforcement seems better Hallmarks
in heavy-handed are some of the past the
council and despite protestations to the
country The Masks slipped a little bit
yesterday and where Mr Lee said
expressed eagerness to start separate
enforcement proceedings against the
existing hard standing which Mr Hawley
it now turns out had missed out of the
current enforcement notice in your
recall it was very uh sort of inexcited
I said well it would be material
consideration if we start enforcement
perceiving
Mr holig is also Keen to take into
account lawful extensions to Brynwood
house
um
apparently on the basis that he thought
it got too big already there was a
certainly uh what he had to say was
pregnant with that uh that type of
sentiment
um that was never an appropriate thing
to do and heavy-handedness is the
planning matter in and of itself but
what it does do is help to illuminate
what the opponent would identify as a
persistently overplayed hat in terms of
assessment and approach
and family to the point where the parent
didn't feel able to return procedures
yesterday it should indicate something I
sort of indicated should come if the
inspector required to attend there's a
really real sense that councilor send
them out for differential treatment and
of course a council is under a duty to
act dispassionately and in the public
interest
it's not clear there wasn't any evidence
of how other people have been treated
differently
you've not seen the correspondence I
mean you don't have any trouble with it
okay all right so uh you know it's not a
planning matter as such but there there
is
yeah don't worry about it because it's
not you know um
I I will be considering whether the
development is acceptable or not not
whether other people have been treated
absolutely yeah it's not clear to the
opponent whether Miss lethid was not
break properly or whether he's not so Mr
Hawley didn't know but it's a matter of
considerable regret that the council
refused to meet the opponent to discuss
a constructive way vertically you've got
the relevant correspondence
when reminded that crisis must leave
that attempt to say well look the
council had taken the view that it
wasn't worth them
uh meeting well that was an appointment
Mr Telford spoke to Mr Purcell as he's
encouraged to do by a national planning
guidance to try and narrow the issues
and reach an acceptable compromise a lot
of the council did was shut up shop and
the appellant says that a sensible Way
Forward could be negotiated
at the very least a discussion should
have been had and as a result here we
are some of that's the council's own
making
planning course morally neutral whatever
the council thinks of the apparent
person of these appears should be
determined in all the way as of course
they will be so there's no question
absolutely as we went over yesterday
they will be but they should be
appela um in discussion with the
appellant on Wednesday the 29th first
time that I was able to take
instructions instructed the occupant
agreement logic recently decided to
pursue a romantic relationship setting
up home as a result I was going to be
vacating the property and as a result
about that reflecting on that matter the
Appellate reason it came to the view pla
no longer served any purpose so appeala
was withdrawn and that has shortened the
ceilings
so pob grounds of appeal grounds AF and
a newly invoke ground G
uh having now heard the evidence
dependent submits the following it's
Common Ground Brynwood house brimwood
Lodge has seen only in distant views in
the South and are viewed with a high
hedge and Rising around to the north
they're forming a backdrop
it's agreed the property isn't visible
from the military brain on public
right-of-way it's only visible from new
road to the South where any views are
broken through substantial head roads
and mature trees
it's agreed that both buildings are set
into the bank that forms the northern
boundary of the site
indicated the oak frame and Oak Club
buildings will weather into a silver
gray finish they're recessive the
building's sitting Gardens which are to
be landscaped and their appearance will
be softened further
you don't accept we've already touched
on this really in one of the points in
response with the parents accepts the
locally designated Landscapes valued
landscape however it doesn't really say
the council anywhere because of the
agreed lack of visual effects and
absence of indirect character effects so
these appeals are dealing with buildings
within a domestic cartilage it's not a
case about landscape and visual effects
on a valued landscape Council doesn't
really contend that EVS with any
conviction at the very least the
buildings preserve the Valley Landscape
no conflict with that policy what do you
mean by lack agreed lack of vision
effects
in terms of the visual enclosure
the view the view shed
you can't see it from the
okay well the council's cases that there
is there is a visual effect that's what
yeah they do but when you come to it you
can't see it but it's kind of it's just
the word agreed
what is it well what is agreed you uh
indicated yes they'd be on the site
visit right to the outset that it's only
signal just abused the South really my
my point 1.2
I've only seen a disabilities to SRP
with the high hedge Rising lands to the
north forming a backdrop probably not
visible from Milford lane or public
right-of-way uh any 112612
it's only visible New Road
so those are
um whether or not they then constituted
breach as a matter of you Council say
they are but the actual extent of the
visual effects is agreed seems to me
we are not disagreeing if we are not
disagreeing as I understand it in any
way about the locations the viewpoints
from which you can or cannot so it's the
agreed extent of vision effects rather
than the agreed lack of visual effects
yes so I suppose the view the view show
the the where the visible the visibility
the discernability of these buildings is
not in disagreement that is an agreed
position what you then do with those
views which are available is obviously
amount of you and councils say there's a
breach of policies we say absolutely not
all right thank you so I hope that's
clarified thank you clarified that
um
the the garage in what's been described
as unfinished building uh oh it's 680
you've got my point you know what's
coming on that but our separate
buildings and they should be treated as
separate entities both have different
characteristics functions and results in
different types of effects one may be
found to be acceptable even if the other
is not vice versa separate detailed
separate and detail that should be
assessments that part needs to be
carried out so accepted of course both
burnings are inappropriate the
government's in the green bar for the
paragraphs 149 uh paragraph the purposes
paragraph 149 however properly applying
the nppf uh you serve got to determine
how much harm there is to the green bar
before applying substantial weight to it
as of course is required by paragraph
148 any assessment of potential arms of
the green belt by a reason of
inappropriateness will need to consider
impacts on openness both spatial and
visual and relative harm to the five
purposes including laminate in the green
bugs only when that exercise has been
done the substantial weight can be
applied to them to the Quantum of
definitional hum course to do this uh so
this needs to be added any of the harm
resulted from The Proposal court of
appeal date with that in the regular
drone case of it should be very familiar
and this is Patterson been able to turn
in the court of appeal uh when it may
play in the very presence of any of the
harm in the then wording it's not
changed
but in the then wording was sufficiently
and deliberately set apart from harm to
the green belt so as to imply that it
was dealing with Harmon and non-green
bowel context so that will be visual
heart Heritage architecture or traffic
on whatever it is uh in the case of both
buildings the Quantum of definitional
harm and any other harm has been
exaggerated by the council this matters
because it feeds directly into the very
special circumstances equation if
there's a lower degree of harm then the
other considerations need to do less
work to clearly outweigh such aggregated
harm
as part of its cost claim Council seen
content to submit the case on ground a
in the pob was hopeless uh and I already
made the point I mean that's just
some tenable given the full day of
inquiry time which we spent discussing
just that
uh whatever the outcome of these appeals
the appellant retains his permitted
development rights I think Class C so
I've got reference to to Mansell and
tombridge uh well Justice Limbaugh I'm
confirming the legal considerations in
determining materiality will fall back
in the indicated fully familiar with
this but just to summarize the basic
principle
is that for a prospect to be a real
Prospect it doesn't have to be probable
a likely possibility will suffice no
rule of law that in every case the real
Prospect will depend for example on the
site having been allocated for the
alternative developments in the
development plan or planning permission
having been granted for that development
or on there being a firm design for the
alternative scheme or on the landowner
or developer having said precisely how
he would make use of any committed
development rights available to him
under the gpdo in some cases that degree
of clarity and commitment maybe
necessary in others not this will always
be a matter for the decision makers
planning judgment in the particular
circumstances of the case in hand
the clear desire of the landowner to
develop and maximize value of the site
was sufficient to demonstrate a real
Prospect to the class key gpda format
position in that case
well here I'm Charles Evans the opponent
has a clear desire and obviously
um the financial means to maximize his
use of permitted development rights
so whatever argument there might be
about demarcation of cartilage there is
Curtis of course there is and the
appellant will construct Class E
buildings in it
um now the legal advice that uh
now that I've got involved will be to
apply for a Clockwork before starting to
build again
um it's a realistic fallback position
which will be exercised by the appellant
and whilst the appellant has not yet
applied for that cluppard that is not a
prerequisite so we are absolutely within
the FourSquare within Madison and
tonbridge you don't need to have drawn
up plans you don't need to have applied
for your clockwood what you do need to
show is clear desire and that is
absolutely evidenced in this case this a
landowner will be building classy
buildings
so the buildings are constructive of
such expensive materials that they will
be used
by raising the wooden construction The
Unfinished building can be modified to
meet all qualifying Criterion
um it's not for me to speculate that you
can take a view in relation to taking
the you know the legs off the it's
obviously on a slope but you can take
the legs off you can modify one of the
one of the window openings or the
apertures on the hillside we've got the
door seems to be perfectly
straightforward to do that to to meet
qualifying criteria now whilst the
appellant doesn't need to prove the
points at this juncture potentially uses
for the unfinished building include an
indoor digital golf range digital
shooting range and cover for vintage and
performance cars
um I will say that um
obviously it's just going to make make
the Judgment but I've said yesterday
that I didn't have sort of expert
evidence about modification but when I
look at that unfinished building for
example
um I find it very difficult to see how
you could reduce that
in by two meters in height and call it a
modification it would be
a completely different
completely different building
um to function in a completely different
way what's supposed to be used as a
garage and and so on uh golf virtual
golf and play shooting if you took two
meters off you'd virtually you'd
virtually remove what what you might
describe as the lower
floor without a story but we I I mean
the answer is no if you just take change
pictures I mean it doesn't need to be
with us yeah well the suggestion was it
because it's a timber frame you
basically just cut off part of the
timber frame what I'm saying is what you
just indicated that you you change a lot
more than just the timber at the height
of the the legs the important thing is
for the client I mean well the important
thing in planning sense for this
decision is that you um
have to be satisfied that there is a
clear desire
to use the
to use the classing rights that my view
is is absolutely the case you know here
so the important point from uh or the
important thing from the client's
perspective is to reuse the very
valuable materials that's the oak to use
as much of that as you can so whether
that is by cutting off the uh cutting
off the supporting structure or whether
or not that is removing the roof and
lowering the pitch
you will have to form a view but
it doesn't have to be that building
but all I'm just all I'm want to be
clear about is is what it is I'm
comparing
what what's there you you so you are
comparing to I I appreciate that that
there will be permitted development
rights yeah there will be a cartilage
whatever that is and whatever is
constructed
um
will have to comply with the um the
limitations in the PD rights yes but in
terms of comparing the impact of that
with what's there I'm trying to build a
clear picture of what that might be and
what I'm saying to you is I don't I
can't see on the evidence that it's just
that building but lower
right I I I'm I don't have plans we
don't have plans I haven't had time
maybe I would you know if I'd had time
to uh to take instruction on that we
could have put some things I do have
some plans but I'm not going to start
putting evidence you know in in now but
all you need to know is that those
materials are so valuable to the um to
the Landover that they will be used
to
maximize
and classy rights
so whether or not that is with a reduced
pitch whether that is by taking off uh
some of the uh height or combinator out
of the
um supporting frame or a combination of
both it is going to be using those
materials
and so the point of comparison sir we
say is a you don't have a precise plan
but telling it but Mountain says you
don't need to do that is for you to
envisaged as best you can
um a building with
Oak
with a Target roof with some
fenestration
but at the maximum metrics that the the
class C would allow
I don't think I can put it higher than
that I do not have a plan to say it's
going to be these
I do know
um that the talking to the client that
they that he's spoken to the
um countries are we getting into
evidence now
well
there are that there are conversation
stuff that's why I'm not going to put
plans with them absolutely not right but
conversations have started about what
you would do
right a house of Premium quality is my
15 uh how Supreme in quality like
brimwood's house uh can expect to have a
commensurately large garage to
um house a variety of vehicles uh
including equestrian vehicles uh
motorhome sports car and various types
of motorbikes now it was obvious on the
site visit that this particular
landowner has a passion for cars and
expensive cars and gizmos and all but
leaving that aside even if it was of
course this is a decision that's made
into the future a future occupier of you
know of a house
which happens to be the most expensive
in the postcode is going to expect
somewhere to park cars Range Road car
horse box whatever it is that is
absolutely
um you know that would go with that type
of property even if you are discounting
the quads and all the other things
supplying relevant case law and
professional judgment the area red red
is the cartilage of brimwood house
we say that Sports by investigations
carried out by the council in 2015 in in
alleged uh or unauthorized Earth or
explanation the poor basement around the
pond all of which were within the
cursive issue but we say you don't need
to go that far as definitively
identifying cartilage I noticed the
councils pull back from that a little
bit in its closing it's not asked you to
do that it's sufficient to give full
weight to the fact that classy buildings
built out to the maximum metrics Allowed
by the qualifying criteria will come
forward on the site
and it's um you know not not Beyond it's
not that okay which is not that big uh
it's obvious there's Curves in it you
know I think just leave that to you
um but for planning purposes and the the
um
cell switch has been set out in uh in
Madison and tonbridge we think you've
got enough to follow for you
um a comparison could be drawn on this
basis as Mr tubbard indicated the
current buildings have been designed to
work with the existing topography can't
be seen from the surrounding areas other
than the limited uh points which you
will you noted but Class E buildings in
different locations over which the
council would have no control actually
maybe more harmful it doesn't maybe that
actually you may even make it worse have
to form a view on that
in the case of the garage as Mr talc had
said the fallback position is that a
multitude of vehicles will be parked
on the hard standing uh which we now
know was excluded from the enforcement
that it is and as you would have seen
today that's a reasonably substantial
bit of uh hard standing it can
accommodate a number of vehicles
um that's clearly less desirable in
Greenbelt than parking vehicles within a
high quality well-designed garage
that'd be visible from the south across
the valley where Vehicles will be more
conspicuous than the garage the garage
is a material improvement over an open
parking area which already exists as
part of the cartilage
underground a
um planning permission can only granted
the breach of development control
relation to notice
um Council stated the wrong Testament
session internal I think we've dealt
with this this is the point about
finishing off so you probably don't need
anything needs Arena
20 then as a result the four back
positions could take place anywhere
within the land there's red current
sighting design of the buildings most
appropriate location with the least
visual impacts and we say that should
carry a significant way
any determination the very special
circumstances exist of course that's the
matter for you alone there's no
prescribed list and in the particular
circumstances here the degree of harness
the Greenback resulted from definitional
harmless any other harm is extremely
Limited and the two considerations
relied on by the appellant which
particularly the fallback position are
sufficient to clearly outweigh such
aggregated harm
and Council we again just repeating
myself exaggerated the Harmon unfairly
denounced the fallback so we're doing
the opposite aren't we they're
exaggerating the harm so no weight to
the fallback we're saying actually
um let's look at it sensibly harm has
got to be looked at this personally and
the the other factors carry greater
weight when you say the material
considerations relied on by the opponent
most particularly the fallback position
just remind me what what other
considerations were well see there are
so the materials themselves
the uh there are sustainability issues
aren't there about reuse of buildings
that there are other things that you
might take into account
principally it's the fallback position
of moving within the within the with it
within you know within the curtainage
thank you
so what we say look ground a uh Dean
permission very special circumstances to
exist
around F then I'm assuming ground Aid
fails bounce and it's prompted demolish
the buildings is sufficient to remedy
the bridge so as discussed during the
session yesterday Council has been
overzealous in some regards taken an
unorthodox stance in others so the
notice only needs to refer to building
uh and it was helpful clarification that
it wasn't intended to catch the existing
hard standing on which the vehicle is
doing will park so when I say unorthodox
that that point relates to you know hard
standing underneath the building I've
never seen that before but it's being
clarified doesn't matter
um providing the notices modified to
extend to the building only then that
will suffice I don't accept that is just
clarification it is a change and I think
that the point that you were discussing
with Mr Leith and it feels to me that
that is a
reduction
it's not just a clarification the notice
on its face is uh overstating
requirements and I think on the basis
that of the discussion yesterday the
council is wrong on that I know why Miss
Luther said that because of his uh have
his cops claim but actually it seems to
me the the appeal on ground F should
succeed
um ground G
um having taken instructions from the
appellant it became apparent what a
specialist job deconstruction movement
stories B specialist contractor harder
programming current circumstances given
the positive skilled labor Council
indicated
um it wasn't overly concerned about time
skeletons it wasn't too long and what we
say is look six months preferably nine
no legitimate purpose enforcing the plan
to rush a technical job over the winter
months
that's an activity
including remarks then based on the
evidence it's called the appellant
respectfully request the ground they
should succeed ground F dealt with above
failing all that ground G should succeed
um I think it's just overall right look
I understand people get excited and
councils get excited about things but
other than fluffing up the feathers of
the council making neat legal points and
all of that get all of that in planning
terms it makes absolutely no sense to
rip down
high quality buildings made of top
quality materials just to see them moved
a few meters away and made a couple of
meters lower to reach
and what we say is look that's a
colossal waste of time money materials
to do so and it's something antithetical
to sound planning and the public
interest so I'm not saying either that's
a license for people just to do what
they want but here
the technical breaches that there are in
relation to class E mean that yeah it's
outside uh they're outside permitted
development rights but you are going to
get the exercise of PD rights you are
going to get classy buildings this house
does need a garage and you know there is
good reason for uh and another ancillary
ancillary building
in determining and grounding you've got
to stand back with respect and say is
this actually what we should be doing
given the very limited degree of harm
that there is and just dispassionately
looking at this what a you know what a
waste of time that would be so for those
reasons we say that the um
very special circumstances exist and
their program they should be granted uh
of the dean plan permission to ground
Nation to granting for both of those
buildings
so unless I can further assist those are
my uh closing submissions on the
substance of the planning case no thank
you very much
you're happy you don't need to say
anything else obviously as I say Mr
hardy will get the last word but I think
I've got your case it's very clear
uh thanks thank you so there was one
point where um
there are a couple of ad hominem remarks
there was a point in relation to Crown
death where
um it was perhaps being suggested that I
wasn't being completely straightforward
uh I will certain act on instructions
if perhaps I misunderstood what men and
a friend said
right okay
thank you very much indeed
um
so 20 to 20 to 1. um
so
um have you got your final costs
yes sir I I have this email address I
appreciate my own friend for whatever
reason didn't uh get it what I wonder
um and very well we are in a public
inquiries if it's worth me making the
application and then perhaps a journey
and giving them a little different time
to think about this and make whatever
amendments he wishes to make uh just to
hear I've not I've not read the email
it's actually just to hear it read uh it
would be good and then yeah and that'll
take us to a convenient Point well yeah
yes although if I can deal with it
because I have made some amendments to
this and I'll be you know pragmatical
that I can do they do it before lunch
you know yes because if I can avoid a
long lunch of German I will oh of course
yeah
um so I'll hand it round
thank you very much
thank you uh so for the benefit of those
um listening this is an updated
application in fact I should probably
put that in the tram lines at the top
um
um and also by watching maybe aware that
you so requested that an application for
cost was submitted on the 1st of
November uh various things have changed
to clarify our request I knew there was
going to be an application because and I
didn't request an application
the the request was that any application
for course or or the intention
application course be submission by the
first of November this is an updated
application to reflect uh changes since
then uh it has only been as you'll see
uh slightly modified
so this is an application uh by the
council for a partial but significant
Award of costs against the Appellate Mr
Robert Hadfield the appellant the
appends period against Council decision
to achieve uh against two enforcement
notices and I've described them there
turning into the page uh this
application is made having regard to the
planning practice guidance on appeals
no unless unless to the public you think
it's uh no I think we can summarize it
for the public that Awards of costs can
be made where there has been
unreasonable behavior which also results
in in wasted costs that's and then it
gives examples of a non-exhaustive list
list of examples of what that might be
but that's the basic that's the number
of it
thank you sir and then I I've said um
I I read from paragraph seven uh the
application arises from the unreasonable
conduct of the appellant both on
procedural and substantive grounds the
council applying for an award of costs
in which the work undertaken to date in
relation to the group of officers and uh
Council and Advising preparing for the
inquiry and Drafting and reviewing
appeal documentation and evidence as
well as for other administrative costs
in relation to the abortion inquiry that
sat on 6th of September 2022 these
admissions cost include the need to
unnecessarily book meeting rooms range
Refreshments set up provide web
streaming using equipment that might be
needed elsewhere send notifications to
interest parties and liaison arrange to
accommodate other interested parties uh
this this paragraph is new and it
responds to points uh amazing learning
friends initial response senior City the
book is Refreshments had already been
organized well before it's agreed to
hold the inquiry virtually
uh further and for the point is a doubt
the council is applying for the late
withdrawal of ela and the POV ground C
and the substantive weakness dependence
case in relation to PLA and gram B
grounds a and
at Sea so it isn't restricted
um to um
I did refer to one million videos is 6th
of September 2022 in fact ground C was
in the early application and it was
withdrawn after that date
um I've then set up the chronology so
I'm not sure how helpful it would
necessarily be to read that
um the only uh addition to the
chronology since the last application
um
is is yesterday inquiry museums
dependent withdrew a pla I put just for
10 am I was literally 9 59 as you
remember so we were off to leave the
room
um
and and then the application itself
dependence on reasonable Behavior
justifying a procedural Award of costs
uh Independence lack of Engagement for
6th of September 2022. the opponents uh
the opponents failed to engage with the
inquiry for several months before uh it
was scheduled to sit on the 6th of
September 2022 despite being contacted
on numerous occasions for the council
degree matters such as the required
timetable statement of common ground and
submit approved evidence no response was
received there was then still no
engagement by the appendant after pins
confirmed to the parties on the 8th or
8th of August 2022 after Council
expressed its concerns about the
apparent's lack of Engagement it was not
until 31st of August 2022 that the
opponents sought in a German as a
consequence of his personal reasons
which request was denied by the
inspector
um
and um
just notating and passing I don't think
we've seen your parents at all not even
at the site visit today
while the council is sympathetic to the
personal circumstances of the appendix
agent this lack of Engagement was
unreasonable for following reasons the
inquiry date was set by pins on the 21st
of March 2022 some five months in
advance and you've kind of had an ample
opportunity to inform the council for
kids of any difficulties he was having
in preparing from inquiry
in general request on 31st of August
there's only three working days before
the scheduled inquiry on the 6th of
September 2022
on the 6th of September 2022 their
parents still are not produced a proof
of evidence and anything which is a
draft version of the state would common
ground to the council the day before
which is too late for cuts to be a
degree of final version to send it to
pins
they require SAT in the state of
September 22 dependent failed to attend
um
it's not clear if he's upset then or for
some other reason uh and no Witnesses
attended either uh while the appearance
agent was present he confirms that he
would not be giving evidence
there was no reasonable chance inquiry
could have proceeded without the
appearance or any Witnesses supporting
his case attending
now this Behavior Falls squarely within
the sort of unreasonable behavior
described by the people geography too as
justifying an award of costs against an
appendix on procedural grounds it is
plainly unreasonable indeed the appendix
agent as you will recall sir appear to
accept this when the inquiry SATs can
sit for September 2022.
and then the planet's late withdrawal of
pla the weaknesses in the appellant's
case in relation to ground a which
relied Solon ground D statist has been
commented on frequently by the council
including in the version of the cause
application that was submitted on the
first November 22. those weeks set out
again in this application below the
reason given by the opponent withdrawing
this was because the most recent
document the daughter of the appellants
partner has moved out and I think that's
what was told yesterday I think today
until she's moving out imminently
uh this is not a good reason for
withdrawing the appeal if Brynwood Lodge
had been an independent residential use
for many years since you kind of
attempted to argue another tenant
could have been found and I'll expand on
that if it's still in residential use
today
um
what's the there is no rationalism for
you drawing that
appeal
the fact that the uh
the parents girlfriend's daughter is
thinking about moving out is it has no
bearing on that at all
indeed the use of the property by an
occupy are closely connected dependence
as a way to the council suggestion that
the building was in fact in ancillaries
um
Independence late withdrawal of appeal B
ground C the appends initially relied on
ground C he argued that the unauthorized
buildings the new garage and the
unfinished building did not constitute
planning control as they benefited from
permitted development rights under Class
E
this was said to be because they came
within the cartilage of the lodge
on the 4th of October 2022 and Depends
informed the council he was no longer
relying on this ground no substantive
reasons were provided
this ground formed the main components
that building did not have any
reasonable prospects success you know
friends were very obviously not within
the cartridge of the lodge on no
reasonable analysis could the
unauthorized buildings be considered to
be incidental to the knowledge and the
opponent did not attempt to explain how
this could be so even unauthorized
building these are exactly different
development advice conferred on Degrassi
as a result of the limitations within
paragraph E1
do you dependent's own legal advice
submitted with his stable Decay some
cartilage did not support his own ground
C appeal so this is refer to Brentwood
house and not Brynwood Lodge
as a result of this confusion the
council was obliged to invest further
time and resources considering whether
the buildings could be said to benefit
from committed develop rights under
Class E the Greenwood house was
considered instead
however even if Ringwood house was
considered rather than Brynwood Lodge as
dependent but his case the ground could
still not have succeeded
the councilors argue that the booties do
not come within the cartilage of Bruno's
house but however even if the council
would have formed a view that there was
at least a case that they were the
unauthorized buildings could not be
considered to be reasonably sedented to
bring to which house and were excluded
there's limitations within pan golf E1
as explaining his support is evidence
that's the ground was always uh
misconceived even if every effort were
made to consider that the appendant did
not even try to advance it will be
argued below
it would be arguing that this should
give rise substantive Award of costs for
this reason it is argued that it should
recognize the surgeon water costs
however even if you so were to decide
that there was a time when it was
reasonable for the Appellate to rely on
the ground that the opponents should
have realized much sooner that it stood
no reasonable Prospect to success and
spread the council the need to invest in
time and resources responding to it that
there was no material change
in circumstances
and and then I tend to see the depends
on reasonable Behavior justifying a
substantive Award of costs but the
appeal submitted by the parents are
unusually weak
the PPG is clear over 53 that that
anapellanity is at risk of an awarded
cost being made against them if the
appeal or ground pill had no reason to
possibility of succeeding
um and so the reference to a lack of
Merit is is uh refers back to pppg
almost all of the grounds of appeal
submitters have no reasonable Prospect
of succeeding
pla ground D when the pit when the cat's
consider dependence LDC application 2021
which which is before you search the
lack of credible physical and
documentary evidence to support the
alleged residential use of the lodge for
the relevant period was discussed in the
officers report despite this and the
reviews of the application the
appendages failed to produce further
evidence for this appeal
indeed even though the lack of evidence
was again discussed when the inquiry sat
on the 6th of September 2022 no further
Evidence was provided even when there
was an opportunity even when further in
its General in relation to people
submitted no further evidence on ground
D that was put in the ground had has no
reason Prospect success as regarding
costs the council independent being
appeal
um
and of course it was withdrawn at um a
minute to midnight as it was
appeal at the ground C are set out above
the opponent has indicated he no longer
relies on his ground sleeping under the
plb but there is really stated this
ground never had any reasonable
prospects instantly justifies as fancy
would cost time resources it felt
expensive than dealing with it
appear will be ground a
year Penance appear underground over
there's no reason to prosperous for
success
now the other authorized building is in
force against under and the green bus
will only be acceptable if they're not
inappropriate developments or being very
special circumstances right they're
plainly inappropriate development that's
great there's been no serious attempt to
argue very special circumstances
but further the planet is actually a
reasonably nice photo of God's Eisen ppf
or Greenbelt policies in the development
plan in authorized buildings and this is
in their evidence the unauthorized
building is a plainly inappropriate
development in the green belts in that
case that kind of significant volume of
footprint to development on the site
one of the buildings is unfinished and
we say it's quite clearly unfinished and
what was not completed at the time of
the
notice cannot be completed by a ground a
appeal Arnold but there's no
misconception there
the appellant assaulted down play its
spatial impact by introducing fullback
arguments which cannot lawfully be
carried out as a bonus book do not meet
the requirements of permitted
development and that appears to be now
accepted the appellance has not
addressed or assessed the visual impact
upon openness his status do not cover
winter views and they're limited with
regard to provision the visibility
you've used within the special landscape
area
on any reasonable objective notice when
taking expression and visual factors
together the Appellate should have seen
that it could only be concluded that the
impact upon the openness of the
Greenback would be negative
he therefore should have been aware that
any harm to the openness agreement would
be a consideration to which the
substantial weight would be afforded
Independence argues about vehicle
parking weak and could not possibly
amount to very special circumstances
sufficient by themselves or cumulatively
to outweigh clearly the green belt and
other harm
onto the green person other home the
unreasonable is dependency in advance in
the ground further justifies the
substantive award
of costs uh for the reasons of part of
the appendix conducts and these appeals
has been unreasonably in numerous
respects and justifies a partial but
significant rewarded costs on both
procedural and substantive grounds so I
dealt also briefly yesterday just
respond to an appointment there was an
issue about whether the councils refused
to engage with the appellant the council
has engaged with the Appellate over many
years and on many occasions there was
one particular email which I think is
before you
where
um the appellant made
um
quite specific
requests
uh
he was not performing I I think one of
them is that the council just dropped
its Grand a appeal
um
clearly sorry the council was I think
that's why I think if I get the email up
I'll not be
yeah
so a specific
um deal was suggested to the council
um
so you know we're the council's asked to
concede on a new garage
um and see to accept that it wasn't
inappropriate development I was
appropriate development in the green
belt and and that
well doesn't even make sense without the
special circumstances this this was just
before the appeal uh what was being
asked for the council there was no
prospects of the council
uh agreeing uh to these points and it
was perfectly reasonable for the council
uh to
um
indicate that there that there was no
point in discussing those matters
further the council's under no
obligation whatsoever as to do so and
has engaged
with the appellant
on many many occasions over several
years
so unless I can assist you further that
is the cost application as a half of the
council
thank you
um now I said I I was um you know I
would avoid a long lunch break mechanics
because like a most condemned men I ate
a very big breakfast this morning
anticipating this eventually but if
anybody does need a break just let you
know but how long would you need to
respond no I don't think I do actually I
mean I can there's a couple of
extemporary points I can make uh but I I
think that what I have written
um is going to be a good basis so
there's two points one is the things
that you said about the uh inquiring the
6th of September the difference between
a German I need to just doctor it for
that purpose and then there's a couple
of points in response but I'm happy to
go on right but I will just adjourn just
briefly
um break and call it till five past one
okay
foreign
closings missions
and energy of course your costs
application if you if you have your cost
response if it is immority yes sure
it's not bypassing anyway so
by the way just I've now received the
email with your updated costs
okay
thank you very much
and just before you start
um Mr hardy may I also ask that you that
as far as your written closings are
concerned and the have already got this
Hardy's updated sorry Mr leatheads
updated cost application but if you
could email the closings and the
response to the case officer as well the
reason for that is now that we've got
electronic files unless they're emailed
in they will net they will never appear
on
yeah I mean Mr Tubb has been dealing
with that do you know who the the K I
don't even know Craig Maxwell but if if
you address it to
um what was it Ian
seem E2 then even if he's not there yeah
that's fine can I also say that um
yesterday I promised to give you copies
of the legal authorities so there was
time in tonbridge there was
um Sam Smith's Oxford Farms there was
also I referred to Red Hill Aerodrome as
well so if you're happy with that and
I'll copy that to the accounts and then
you've just got them I'm sure you've got
them all ready
in which case if I if I I I am relying
on those and I think you ought to have a
copy of those if the council is uh is
agreeable to that I'll copy them in when
I send it to you
yeah I mean you're not saying anything
more about them than than has already
been said so that's fine exactly but if
you when you send those in if you say
um as requested by the inspector
otherwise they'll just send it later
I'll put them all in one email yeah so
that all the documents go in as
requested I think rather than yeah okay
that's great thank you
uh
good wealth by way of um
overview it seems to me to be an odd uh
costs application and a number of
respects and also one where
I think the the general attitude of the
council uh that was again betrayed by
those uh of Peace comments in the under
at the end about the meeting I mean
there is an ongoing obligation
uh
on the part of an authority to try and
narrow issues and to act in the public
interest and what my own friend has done
is misread that email because there is a
telephone conversation which you will
see
that was telephone discussions between
Mr Telford and Mr purcella which a whole
range of things were discussed and what
came out of that was a one proposal uh
that was up for discussion uh but it
wasn't the only thing it wasn't a you
know take this or or leave it it was
there for for discussion on what the
council did we shut up and shop and say
we're not prepared to meet past the
criticism so what what what what the
council strategy there is characterize
that as a single shark it absolutely
wasn't and of course yesterday when it
positions me
um substantially yesterday we were told
there was no refusable accounts to meet
at all about now has fallen away I think
now the evidence is before you
by web response let's go to my text and
we'll pick up some other points there's
a
we know it's uh a response an updated
position in writing is expected from the
Council on the evening of first of
December I didn't receive it I'm not
saying it wasn't but I didn't get it
until this morning uh I received it from
Mr Lee then
um any Amendment will be considered
subsequently well I'm saying I don't
need that other than uh extemporary
remarks it's distinctly unattractive for
applications of costs
which doesn't sit well with accountant's
responsibility to act fairly
proportionately in the public interest I
I go further I think if cast accounts on
a very poor line personal tragedy in
this case breast cancer is not something
which should be used as a springboard
for a climate costs and a planning
appeal
certified as advising the council we
wouldn't be making this sort of
application the factual circumstances in
this case may be unusual but they're
well known to the council
significantly no submission submissions
are made against the appellant itself or
submissions concern the opponents agent
uh Mr Telford
and the circumstance of this case the
planet hasn't acted unreasonably
proceeded or substantively such that the
partial award costs sought by the
council should be granted
so fracture material largely agreed
including the chronology of events uh
largely agree there's some commentary in
the chronology I don't accept that but
it's not I don't take too much time up
with that paragraphs on the PPG which he
quoted are well known uh and don't need
to be repeated
um it is just worth a reference to
paragraph 49 when you come to look at it
about um it's obviously nothing
exhaustiveness but where a council
refuses to enter into uh pre-application
discussions or provide information when
a more helpful approach would have
resulted in either appeal being
embroidered together or issues being
narrowed then that would reduce the
expense associated with the appeal well
that absolutely fits in with the points
I've made about trying to narrow issues
and the council saying no
has currently articulated the claim from
the council's poorly articulating
unclear
um
so paragraph eight and this was on the
basis of what I had last night rather
than that today and it picks up on a
discussion actually that you and I had
yesterday said which it was that
paragraph eight
um was in the section headed the
application in outline
an expressly stated that any cost claim
is only relating to aborted costs
reputable to the aborted inquire that
open on the 6th of September 2022
paragraph eight
came immediately after paragraph seven
which stated that the application arises
from the unreasonable conduct of the
Appellate both in procedural and
substantive grounds so a fair reading of
that was paragraph eight was
circumscribing what had been set out in
paragraph seven now you yesterday said
well look you've got to read this as a
whole encourage the appellant to look at
paragraph 22 as was but that's not
inconsistent in the way that the the
matter being interpreted the council
hasn't been clear that's been clarified
this morning that's fine and as I wrote
this last night and it seemed to me that
the way Mr Leith had set this up
um just was wasn't clear and the
paragraph 8 following paragraph seven
was circumscribing what the claim is
about
whilst Quantum isn't a matter the
discussion at this stage uh and again
there has been an amendment to what uh
or reply application this morning but
it's submitted that costs associated
with booking meeting rooms and arranging
refreshments
uh were not needed for what could have
been a full uh virtual event
um there are no costs associated with
using equipment that might have been
needed elsewhere I noticed that but it's
been dropped uh from the uh version this
morning
unless evidence is provided that
otherwise a necessary high costs really
occurred in which there is a norm I have
to say it's very
scratching around if we're talking about
some 19 Poppy and uh well that would be
it because I haven't seen anything else
that's not available it's good coffee
though
it's very difficult it's a very good
coffee but uh I mean in fact if that you
know that is an unusual
um item to include in a cost claim for a
council there we go notifications are
perceived as a part of the statutory
responsibilities of a local planning
Authority
didn't get paid that's what they do it's
a job in this paragraph alone
demonstrates the heavy-handed nature of
the applications the healthy degree of
overwriting parts of Mr like that which
is something which isn't something
that's characterized by the sets of
submissions depending the responsible
things and strip to Mr Telford as his
professional agent Mr telephone's wife
and I've asked him he doesn't mind the
disclosing he's diagnosed with breast
cancer January 2022 very seriously or
very quickly
um Mr Telephone became a full-time carer
and forced to put work matters in
abeyance
I think it is
difficult
um to comprehend uh the emotional and
physical strain that he was under you
would have appreciated Mr Telford is in
the um
Twilight years in his career if I can
put it like that uh somebody who is uh
you know an emotional sentient person he
was rocked by what's happened he puts
his hands up and he says yeah um I
couldn't really cope may I just make one
comment about this and that is that um
when when I do the cost decision end or
report I will make very very limited
reference to those circumstances that
does not mean that I haven't fully
appreciated their depth and significance
but for example you said to me
um Mr Talbot doesn't mind this being
disclosed but it's information about his
wife and I don't have you know with the
gpdr it's a bit difficult nowadays I I
don't have yeah I think that's
understood it can be personal so I'm
just flagging that up when the I'm
referring very general terms those
things but not in any case it's
important absolutely right of course
it's important to know what that is
because some people could say well there
was a bit of illness in the family or
whatever you don't know but this is
something that goes right to the heart
of you know
of Life uh and it's that bigger thing so
lack of Engagement
um whilst the lack of Engagement alleged
in paragraphs one and two of the
application on the parts of Mr turkett
is factually correct
um and I should say of course these
paragraph references are to the as was
uh claim
um it's perfectly understandable given
the personal tournament while it was
going through um it may be a matter of
regret that he didn't seek to pass his
work Road on to another planning
professional he can and should be given
uh forgiven for not thinking more
clearly
paragraph 1A uh he was selling Council
records that no responses received the
allegation is not that Mr Telford was
evasive or unhelpful which he has never
been let me conform of you Mr Telford uh
sitting in a nice chat but circumstances
was simply too much for him to go with
um papers are putting a drawer emails
were not read no work was undertaken on
this file or any other file as a result
of those caring responsibilities
so by later August Mr Mrs Temple's
position had improved to some extent
he's still very seriously ill that's why
he's not here today
um she's in hospital
um this was the point on uh there came a
point on the 31st of August that Mr
talford sought
um uh actually postponement rather than
a journalist I think that's your is your
point I think it was I hadn't
I think he was secretly postponed I
haven't gone back to to check the emails
but you'll know whether it was a
postponement yeah well my basic point is
that you open and adjourn
hearings of inquiries I hadn't ever
opened at this stage at the inquiry so
it is postponement of the commencement
of it rather than what instruments I
absolutely understand that difference
what I mean is I'm not sure whether in
his own language Mr Telephone applied
for the German statement yeah I think I
think you may have expressed it in terms
of the German obviously once we've
gotten to the 6th of September then
that's what it was but yeah that's what
I was meaning obviously I know the
difference but I wasn't sure what he had
physically applied for because I haven't
gone back to checking emails okay so the
obvious and decent thing to do is for
the council to accept tragic
circumstances agree to make a joint
application for a a postponement and it
should be of the inquiry to pins
um new procedural timetable could have
been set up set up the council didn't
take that opportunity and it you know
the council itself decided to incur
expenditure when it did not need to do
so that was a choice for it and such
expenditures she shouldn't be laid at
the door of the uh appellant and it
might be late but I've had experience
recently and it was two days ago Council
said yeah absolutely uh and there was a
I've had it both ways round
um so it was an opportunity that the
council didn't take rather than agree to
a postponement
it was the decision pins to open the
inquiry on the 6th of September I just
say that Mr Telford could make then a
further application or could make an
application for a gym whichever it is
procedural course amount of the use Sir
Mr Talcott had no choice to appear and
make his request
um however respectfully that inquiry
session we say could have been avoided
now Mr Turbo communicated he wasn't in a
position to proceed on 6th of September
it should have come as no surprise to
the council that no Witnesses were in
attendance
um the inquiry is never going to be
effective on that basis and the council
was aware of that and fact
because I understand it to count Sal
came here to the offices didn't need to
do that could have been dealt with
virtually wouldn't have been a it would
have been an hour of his time rather
than a day
um the behavior of the appellant is not
plainly unreasonable I set out in
paragraph three or at all personal
circumstances before Mr Talbert were
devastated uh whilst the council may
have been irritated in a heavy-handed
way it doesn't mean that the qualifying
criteria for an award of costs on
procedural grounds are met and and
cutting it cutting to the chase what you
are doing is
um fixing the appellant who has
appointed a planning agent with costs by
reason of a veteran planning consultant
who lost his head because his wife's got
breast cancer that's what this cost
application boils down to and I say that
is a it should it doesn't sit well with
a public duty of a local authority to
bring this cost application and be it's
not on reason
and a balanced late withdrawal then of
the appeal B ground C
now it's the element of the claims of
that Merit Mr Telford was well enough to
start working again property properly he
was able to consider the state
medication the council and third party
representations
having reached the view of the ground
seeing appealed B wasn't likely to
succeed in light of the reason set out
by opposing parties uh it was a
responsible and reasonable thing to do
to withdraw it at the earliest
opportunity which he did and that's
precisely what a responsible party to an
inquiry required to do now
I think there's a distinction to be
drawn
um between
qualitative arguments about curtainage
and metrics
and you've seen in the papers that
there's a debate oh there's a discussion
about where you measure height from
so the volumetric stuff
and what the council did
was you know provide information I think
there's reference to the case in burden
uh about uh about where you measure
um buildings from so it's not that this
will save us from the start but Mr talb
has said okay well that you know we've
seen the case on the other side
and in metrical terms we're absolutely
not giving up the Curts at this point we
stick biting that right now absolutely
um but the the metrics
would have been
a difficulty facing that classy argument
anyway so what he did was look at that
and go okay well on the basis of Burden
metrics uh either the metrics are such
that you know this isn't going to
succeed so he does the responsible thing
that's exactly what the inquiry
procedure rules ask you to do look at
the other side
review your position and take a view
that's what he did
so just because the council doesn't
agree with the ground of appeal doesn't
make it unreasonable for an appellant
sentence to pursue it so that point
about curtail is absolutely arguable but
it doesn't matter because it's got to be
cartilage and all the metrics if you're
not going to comply with the metrics
well you're not going to succeed in
class E so that was the reason for the
withdraw again whilst Quantum isn't for
determination paragraphs eight to ten
are noteworthy
um the reasons why the council state the
buildings were excluded as a result of
physical limitations within E1 applied
just the same whether it was Brynwood
house or Brynwood Lodge that was being
considered so you know it's a mystery to
me in the way the applications put the
costs about I was all confusion and
David Manley's advising and so on it
doesn't matter
because whether it was in arguments
about curtiligent Brynwood House of
Brynwood Lodge the council was saying
you never qualified anyway because of
the because of the metrics so no
additional work of any sort was required
in that regard it's a good indication of
heavy-handedness and overwriting so
given the personal circumstances Mr
Talbot it's not the case that withdrawal
of ground C should have been
communicated sooner
what was done was reasonable and in
plenty of time everything quoted the
first of December and actually that is
what we're exhorted to do to look at the
other side's case and take a risk a
realistic view that shouldn't result in
across what it costs award against the
apparent person
so unreasonable behavior then justifying
a substantive award
um I mean it's
really odd not to say
it's no basis for a cost claim for the
council to submit the appeals are
unusually weak
um
the recipient of an enforcement note
just has got every right to defend his
or her position and see that tested
before an inspector that is subject to
uh you know examples of unreasonableness
but in substantive terms you know having
a case that the council think is weak
isn't uh not only 27 years I've been
doing this job unreasonable behavior the
sanction of costs is there in respect to
behavior which is just being reasonable
not to judge's stance which the council
may not agree well in the end just comes
down to whether I I consider that the
arguments have no reasonable prospects
of success that's what it comes down to
in the end isn't it
well I think it's got to be uh you know
I think it's got to be a bit more than
that really is it it's got there's got
to be no I mean I don't know whether
unusually weak is into text that would
be a saying look that that's accounts of
stamps I think you'd have to say they're
almost done arguable
I think reasonable prospects that that
indicates to me a 50 50 chance no I mean
no reasonable Prospect of success
um
I I I I think I think that depends on
how you do so to me reasonable prospects
all I'm what I'm saying is that the test
absolutely isn't yeah and I would put it
close to you know being an argument if
it's absolutely if you are running up
against a brick wall and I think that
that what's helpful in that regard is
when you go to the PPG in relation to
examples of substantive
uh unreasonableness
say you have got a fresh High Court
decision
which is squarely online you know on all
fours with your case
and you you know in the teeth of that
carried on I think absolutely that's
unreasonable but I think just having you
know but having factors which absolutely
when you apply
that's enough
but it certainly isn't testable usually
weak that's just that's just
characterization by the council it's
just right I mean so just to get the
wording right this this is the bit from
the PPG yes I hate the length of
references for the PBG there's a
paragraph 53 in the appeals section I'm
just looking at that now so let me turn
that up if I may 53.
51.52
53 yeah yeah so the right of appeals you
exercise in a regional manner propellant
is a risk of an award of cost being made
against them if the appeal or ground of
appeal had no reasonable process of
succeeding and it gives examples of when
that might may occur but those are those
that's the that's the test really isn't
it that's the wording yeah but how you
interpret that I don't think that is a
sort of thing you know 50 50 to me that
means you know goodness if we were as
lawyers uh you know say
thank you
can actually looks like maybe on a 20
Prospect to six
that's a reasonable thing to do
so I'm not going to put a percentage
figure on it but no no but what I'm
trying what I'm trying to do there is
just give it flavor how you get the
point that actually it I I think it's
close to
and therefore that would be an
unreasonable thing to do and I don't
again it will be up to you but I I and I
don't want to be quoted as saying look
that's the absolute test I'm setting one
of
I I but the the expression close to
unarguable
I think fits with my yeah most doing up
close to another and again we ABS yeah
we absolutely do not fall with that
testing
so
um back to my attention pill appeal a
round G
um I mean the elements of Clone points
you know so hopeless the counts element
of the council because the impeller
relied on the Declaration
it's got a special status in terms of
evidence which the council
um persistently ignored
um the opponent was entitled to submit
the evidence was sufficient to discharge
the burden approved uh you know the the
status which uh under the uh under the
ACT uh what that they hold so it wasn't
reasonable to hold that many a case has
been one on a single step at a start day
um the decision of the apparent to
withdraw ground D at this inquiry
session is because the occupant premise
is now relates to me about decision to
withdrawals a separate matter for
obvious reason is not commented on by
the council although it now has been in
the updates
um there should be no water costs
because the second qualifying criteria
that there's been no abortive
expenditure isn't met
um
I think it's right insane the planet
wanted appears to tell me by way of
written representations that was the
original procedural choice
and it was the council's decision to
challenge the uh veracity of the
statutory declaration that led to the
proceedings being uprighted and then to
an inquiry which was then which then
subsisted for a pill B as well so once
appeal a had been elevated to an inquiry
then appeal B was taken with that
the council was bound to attend the
council and Witnesses for the round
table session on a pin B which is always
going to be part of an inquiry format
and which you yesterday sir chose to
maintain as an inquiry even though it
was the only event
but it's even if it had been dealt with
Unwritten representations there still
would have been work involved in
addressing ground D which was ultimately
withdrawn I'm unlikely to to to conclude
that it was unreasonable of the council
to say they wanted to inquire because I
decided an inquiry was appropriate
and it usually is where there's factual
matters in dispute on a on a ground D or
LDC case you other inspectors may take a
different view but that's generally when
the start of the planning is better it's
certainly my my stance yeah so so what
they've got to do is got to show Board
of expenditures so the council continue
to argue or have continued to argue
about the extent of cartilage
it's been a point that they
they persisted
underground a in appeal B so as you know
they are arguing as because it was quite
to you yesterday about where the
curtainage is so in relation to the
fallback position they're saying it's
outside the Perth Legend I've asked you
yeah but we're talking about did we draw
the ground D yes but we're talking about
abortive expenditure they've got to
demonstrate not just that there is a
timing point but it's led to a ball but
as I said even if it had been dealt with
by representations they would have
incurred costs
foreign
way than that and what you've got to
show is that all the qualifying criteria
met you've got to show yes that there's
um Behavior which might lead to which
might trigger that but also a board of
expenditure
so what is the work that's been done
in relation to the um in in relation to
the ground d
um the bulk of that is to do with
curtains because the argument was you're
outside Class C because you are not
within the cartilage
that's their case
but that's that that's that you know the
the ground the appeal a had consequences
for appeal B because of the ground C and
cursing the argument but appeal a was
about whether
the change of use of that building to
dwelling was lawful or not cursors
didn't come into that
well it it did didn't if you look at the
evidence
no the question was whether it had been
used as a separate dwelling
for four years
what
you'll have to form your view on that
but if you go back yeah well I have
formed a view on that unless you tell me
why it's wrong that's that's what I'm
trying to do I just need to if you look
at the pet if you look at the papers no
but but you're saying you say you think
you've got got to establish
unreasonableness and in this case
leave aside the arguments about whether
there was any basis for the ground they
appeared the fact is it's been withdrawn
so primarily the question is or
unreasonableness is whether there was a
good reason for withdrawal and I've
heard what both of you have said about
that yeah beyond that there is a
question of whether
um
costs were wasted and unless you're
saying there was no work or no
significant work involved in responding
to appeal a and whatever form it was
there must have been some waste expense
it's not for me to determine how much it
was but if he's saying they did nothing
I'm saying Minimus I say that they they
cannot demonstrate that that abortive
work
so I can't take it any further than that
I've been there
I mean even if they get even if they get
costs I'll be very interested to see the
bill of lading because it's not going to
be very much
fortunately I don't have to no you don't
have to you don't you don't have to
worry about that but obviously we will
scour over them
um
right okay uh Council argue the closing
this initiative writing secretary sorry
I've lost track of it we're at 290 yeah
yeah
perhaps argue for closing submissions in
writing symptoms
when it could have avoided attendance on
the second I think that was that goes to
the point about
today's costs from today uh in the end
you asked the parties to come back after
the site visit in Sean probably analyzed
as it turned out with Robert P Lane that
was on the first day inquire hasn't been
sorted in the court of expenditure so
that that's um our submission you have
to in the form of you
um appeal Grant appeal B then ground a
um
substantively then I mean we don't watch
this um quite in a spent a full day
discussing around how incredible
councilman I feel rather silly it's
highly unusual we can't make an
application I don't really need to read
it because the point is if it goes to uh
the questionnaire is it close to being
an arguable absolutely not
succeed so whilst the council May
disagree with the case dependent puts no
basis whatever for an application costs
counselor status chance to make
submissions on the merits clearly
misunderstood the fallback arguments
completely ignored the point of
buildings which do comply with
electrical requirements in class C kind
of would be cited elsewhere in the
cartilage and so in doing that they've
ignored judicial Authority in manceland
tonbridge
uh it's not helpful and restricted
cancer set up basic principles of
development Management in the green belt
uh in paragraphs 20th and 20g well aware
of green belt policy in the law
um arguing a case that the council
doesn't agree with isn't unreasonable
at conclusions then see another reason
set out above application is
unattractive in conception and in
articulation
and it's a marketable council that's
become over excited that it seeks to
castigate the case on the planet before
it's been before it's even heard as
being unreasonable to a point that costs
award can be uh should be made Let's
have its chance to make its arguments on
ground and appeal B can do so in the
normal way
um lack of judgment is palpable possible
where they lie of course including
enforcement appears nothing in here uh
there's nothing in here what has
happened here to dislodge that normal
rule so as an application as a result
the application the costs are set out by
the council both in its initial
um statements and in its revised
statement it should fail in its entirety
so for those reasons the applications
whether they are partial procedural
substantial or resistance so unless I
can further assist linking thank you Mr
hardy with costs obviously the applicant
against the last word is there anything
else you need to say thanks a very uh
briefly just a couple of points in in a
response I'm not sure where it gets Mr
Hyde anyway he's not making enough
application for cost but this business
about um this refusal to have a meeting
with
the appellant
um Mr hardy mentions just now that the
council have been talking on the phone
with the appellant
um which was the precursor to the me to
to the email
um
and then decided that following those
discussions and following the email a
meeting wasn't going to get anyone
further that is entirely uh reasonable
the council as I said it engaged with
the opponents on many many occasions
over several years it isn't required to
meet with the appellant
um on any um
give an opportunity if if it's close to
your client there really is no point in
doing so
um it wasn't the case that they're
refusing to engage with in full stop
um there's a factual error
in this
um which is no criticism of my learning
Frenchies he wasn't involved at this
stage he says
in his uh Distributing right
version
um he criticizes
um to
two factors he says that um Mr Telford
just um which paragraph
um well there's there's a general point
about Mr Telford and and and so you
remember from last time just how
um
carefully uh the council uh uh dealt
with this matter uh in both its
corresponds to pins and and at the last
hearing was to tell if it is and it's
very difficult uh Circumstance the
difficulty that the council or the
Council of teammate difficulties in this
uh the first
is that
um
there was just no engagement at all with
the opponent
proofs weren't being produced statement
to Common Ground nothing was coming
forward
but Mr hardy um doesn't seem to be aware
of this uh Mr Telford was engaging with
the council regularly and repeatedly on
other matters
so the council knew
that Mr Telford was able to deal with
work
just
for whatever reason
the appendant wasn't engaging on this
particular case
um
as to
the chronology there's a specific point
in
um the 2.8 and again I'm not sure uh
where it gets Mr hardy but he says the
council didn't take the opportunity
to agree a postponent
um
this is no criticism of um
Mr hardy but so if you go back to the
chronology
which and and again I didn't read this
out so and he may have missed it
but
um
it's on page six of the updated
application
um
the deadline for proofs was the 9th of
August
um no proof was submitted
um
then the council wrote them again on the
25th of August
I I believe pins was copied into that
but the emails before your ab6
and
and then a week or so later Independence
agent wrote pins to request postponement
of the inquiry and I'm
not what it's worth that word is
use the according to the agent
um
this is private matter which we've been
going on since April 2022
um
and then
um so the appendant wrote to pins
requesting the postponement not the
council pins then said
on the 1st of September when inquiry is
going to be opened
and the council didn't respond to Mr
Telford and the appellant
until after pins have said so
um what Mr um
hardly said no I think no Chris is
actually wrong it wasn't the council
refused to postpone pins had already
said that the inquiry would
uh go ahead did I not I just forget
forgive me if I'm wrong but normally
before I make a decision on that I do
seek the views of the other side did I
not ask you the council for a few before
I made that decision on this moment I I
don't what I would normally do but yeah
yeah
there may have been a response an
initial response saying the inquiry is
fixed or whatever but I I believe that
before I said no to a postponement I
asked what you thought about it I sort
of recall you saying that you didn't
want to postpone and very general terms
Council was obviously very sympathetic
yes to Telford circumstances
um but in light of the fact that the
date had been set or passing all parties
had been informed all the room bookings
and everything have gone ahead we
invited
um the inspector to modify the inquiry
to a virtual event and where everybody
could attend remotely one of Mr
telford's reasons was that he wouldn't
be able to travel four hours from his
home in the late District so we felt
that a virtual inquiry would facilitate
his attendance that's it so the virtual
inquiry was offered
um and then we receive notification from
pins that the meeting would sit and he
will be able to make his representations
at that time
thank you sir forgive me is it's a
complex uh web of you know some of which
I wasn't answered to there they are set
out in the um
appendices to the
cost cost application
um
it's in any event this the council was
in a difficult
um position whilst being sympathetic to
Mr Telford circumstances of dealing in
this tougher than a range of other
matters but on this particular matter
absolutely no engagement
um
no no proofs no
um
degree statement of Common Ground
nothing
and they're needing to instruct Council
for
um and inquiry in the other costs that
go with an inquiry and it wasn't the
case so as I remember you you know
especially it wasn't agreed from in
advance that it was going to be case
management
hearing
um I that was muted as a possibility by
you that it could be used as a case
management
hearing yeah so what I wasn't saying is
not going to be any inquiry yeah but it
was one of those factors that even if it
couldn't go ahead there could be some
value
um just to backtrack a little bit what
you said about
um
the council having had Mis engagement
with Mr Telford on other matters I don't
think I can really even take account of
that because
I didn't have evidence of itself it's
not here to respond to that so I I heard
what you said but in all honesty I'm not
going to really there's a response made
in it was a point made in response too I
know I know but I I if I'm I'm not going
to say oh well actually I don't believe
that Mr Tilford wasn't able to to um
deal with this matter because he was
dealing with the Council on other
matters I don't think I can no it's it's
it's a detail but in any event
um and unfortunately many of us would
have been in this same difficult
experience or similar difficult
experience this is an event which had
gone on for
for several months and the council I
think initially sought the advice from
pins or what you know what you do I
think it's the first time I'd been in an
inquiry where just no proofs have been
submitted
pins made clear that the requirement
lived
sorry
the um
yeah
so uh you know the council was
obliged to to go ahead and prepare fully
for for an inquiry it wasn't that The
Inquirer was downgraded to a case
management tiering in September
um it was required to instruct
uh Council and to prepare for a two-day
inquiry
but
and so I'll just turn to my side
nothing nothing further thank you
thank you very much indeed
um and I said yesterday that I
have to look forward to closing
submissions but I'm often disappointed
well that I wasn't disappointed today
both very helpful sets of submissions
and thank you to everybody for your
contributions throughout the inquiry has
made my job
easier
um I have
sort of hinted yesterday at
the woes and travels an inspector in
terms of time scales and stuff what I
can say is to say I always try to get my
decisions out as as quickly as possible
because actually nobody wants that more
than me I like to get things resolved as
quickly as possible but there are
certain obstacles in the way one is that
I had sort of back-to-back hearings just
over a week ago which I've got to finish
the decisions on those I've got a rather
complicated Hearing resuming in a couple
of weeks weeks time and that's and I've
got all my management duties plus
Christmas in the way so it may be it'll
be longer than normal for me but that's
not to say it will be a long time
that's very vague isn't it but I can't
be more specific than that
anyway thank you all very much indeed
unless there is anything else
um
the inquiry is now closed